good morning hickets tuesday so right
now i'm staying about half the time at
an airbnb in cincinnati ohio because
that's where they're filming the turtles
all the way down movie and when i moved
into this airbnb i brought some art with
me so that i wouldn't feel so lonely
looking at the walls like i brought this
print i like and this candide poster and
also this painting sarah made in college
which i really love it always reminds me
of this line in watership down where one
of the rabbits says i don't like
straight lines men make them i wanted to
have the painting with me partly because
it just makes me happy to look at but
also partly because it reminds me that
even the human hand can't actually make
a straight line at least not without
like the help of a ruler because our
bodies are wondrously imprecise but
anyway we're not here to talk about art
i like we're here to talk about the art
that came with my airbnb like there's
put queso in my face oh which you know
isn't to my taste but i can appreciate
it then there's this painting which is
fine but it does kind of seem like it
was made by a machine a hypothesis that
is confirmed when you look up at the
loft and see the exact same painting
just turned on its side but then hank
then when you go to the bathroom behind
the toilet you will find a canvas
printed with the word wanderlust and its
definition i have at least five
questions first and i'm gonna try to say
this delicately this airbnb is in
cincinnati which is a lovely town and i
love being there but when one thinks of
wanderlust does one think of cincinnati
don't get me wrong i live in
indianapolis a town famous for its lack
of wanderlustiness i just think maybe
the wanderlust canvas plays in southern
france but does it play in southern ohio
secondly i know it's hard to find
artwork for a bathroom they are messy
places the humidity changes there are
showers etc but why in god's name did
you choose a canvas it's already damaged
and it doesn't look particularly old
someday baumgartner restoration is going
to have his hands full with this one
thirdly when a work of art is nothing
but a word and its definition printed on
a canvas you need to nail the execution
so here is my question why is it not
centered top to bottom or left to right
now during the long and lonely times
i've spent with this artwork i've often
wondered if perhaps someone
intentionally uncentered it to give it a
slight dissonance and asymmetry a
feeling that something might be rotten
in the state of wanderlust but actually
i think it's just off center that said
authorial intent doesn't matter and upon
reflection my favorite thing about this
artwork by a pretty wide margin is that
it's off center fourthly i understand
you have a limited art budget for your
airbnb i get that but after extensive
googling i know how much you paid for
the wanderlust canvas and what i'm
wondering is why didn't you buy this for
three dollars less or just find an old
image of cincinnati and print it out and
put it in a six dollar frame this is so
much better than wanderlust i mean a
free wiener wurst with each drink what a
bargain lastly did you know that in
cincinnati there is an art school it's
true and there are lots of local artists
making interesting inexpensive work that
you can buy at local art shows which is
my actual advice not just to the owner
of this airbnb but also to anyone living
with undecorated walls put something on
them and not just anything but something
semi-particular to you go to student art
shows at local universities browse etsy
support artists and in the process
you'll get to find out that when you
live with an artwork for years looking
at it through ever-changing eyes you get
to experience something even deeper and
more lovely than wanderlust hank i'll
see you on friday